with the crazy situation in the world
moving apace
as we see systems of technological
control and tracking
take over in the name of kovid
we're hearing strange whispers that
there is a relationship between
the vaccine and the mark of the beast
sometimes this comes associated with all
kinds of wild
crazy ideas and conspiracies but
sometimes we also find the source of
this association
in the stories from the mainstream media
this identification is very intuitive in
many who espouse it
well of course it appears completely
delusional in a form of religious
hysteria
by others so i'm hoping to explain the
meaning
of the mark of the beast as much as i
can
so that we can understand and evaluate
the recent claim that we're
being faced with such a system such a
situation on our horizon right now
so my attempts will be in a few parts
the first video will be an attempt to
explain the emergence of
these beasts in the story and then the
second
will be looking at how and why this is
related to a mark
a mark without which it is impossible to
buy or sell
this is jonathan pajot welcome to the
symbolic world
these videos are a continuation of two
videos i did on the symbolism of 666
the number of the beast and how this
number relates to us today
there was one on the number itself and
there was another video on a speech by
tim cook the ceo of apple
which can help us understand how these
ideas are relevant
in the current situation it would be
helpful to watch those videos though
it's not completely necessary to
understand this one
but to summarize i explained how the
desire to account for everything within
a system even
the fluid margin even the remainder of a
process
is the best way to understand the
problem of
it is in many ways an excess of
perfection
an excess of pride in the possibility of
a totalizing system
so we'll see how this pattern is already
present in the description of the dragon
and the two beasts which we find in
revelations chapter 12 and chapter 13.
so starting in chapter 12 of revelation
the text describes three creatures
a dragon and two beasts
then another sign appeared in heaven an
enormous red dragon with seven heads and
ten horns
and seven crowns on its heads its tail
swept the third of the stars out of the
sky
and flung them to the earth
so this dragon is at the outset in
heaven it is associated with the great
serpent
and so the leviathan it's also
associated with satan
the adversary and it causes a war in
heaven
a war in the order of the principalities
then war broke out in heaven michael and
his angels fought against the dragon
and the dragon and his angels fought
back but he was not strong enough
and they lost their place in heaven the
great dragon was hurled down
that ancient serpent called the devil or
satan who leads the whole world astray
he was hurled to the earth and his
angels with him
the dragon knocks one third of the stars
from heaven to the earth with its tail
we need to understand that as a way of
describing the fall itself
the stars falling to earth is another
way of describing a war in heaven
and the rebellious angels who fall to
earth and to the sea
this is of course difficult for many
people to understand but the points of
light
seen in the heavens were images of gods
or angels for ancient people
and this continues on in this passage
as the dragon uses its bottom its tail
to knock things down he
himself ends up falling to the bottom to
the tail of the world
so the tail here is very important in
terms of an image
humans do not have a tail tails are
associated
with animality with lack of intelligence
the war of the dragon is specifically a
war on intelligence we could say it's a
war on authority and pattern
see a tale is a strange flexible
protrusion which is attached
to the bottom to the back
so this tale is related to the question
of a remainder
to something which cannot be contained
completely
a tale is the last thing
and as an image of the remainder it is a
tool of satan
it is a tool of the adversary now this
is not just some moral admonition with
me wagging my finger at you but
it's just a matter of fact
the mystery of things which are left
over
is the way principalities are attacked
and made to fall
this is true still today if we shine
light on exceptions on remainders
it questions the truth of any definition
or identity
so by wagging a tail by brandishing the
fact of
hermaphrodites for example well i can
challenge the truth of male
and female the process of breaking down
patterns and challenging commonalities
then repeats itself
on earth where the satan is said to lead
the whole world
astray to lead them to be lost to be
broken down
to not be able to find their purpose and
their way
therefore rejoice you heavens and you
who dwell in them
but woe to the earth and to the sea
because the devil
has gone down to you
falling to earth and to the sea is a
disconnect from heaven
from a unite what from what unites the
principalities together
the intelligences together they're
united in their service of god
and their fall brings them into what we
could call a double
existence of earth and sea of constant
conflict between
lower embodied orders and menacing chaos
so a way to imagine this this
relationship between
earth and sea the best way is to imagine
the tides
which come up to the seashores and at
the same time those shores
that are keeping the seas in their place
and this becomes
an image of the cycle of order and chaos
in which these principalities now engage
the reality of the fallen principality
can only be this way
because of course they are wrong about
the way reality works
the world cannot be disconnected from
its higher principles
and ultimately cannot be disconnected
from the infinite good that is god
the ultimate fate of this type of
rebellion is to be thrown
into the abyss but in the meantime
the fall is experience is experienced as
a vacillation
between chaos and tyranny a dragon stood
on the shore of the sea
and i saw a beast coming out of the sea
it had ten horns and seven heads
with ten crowns on its horns and on each
head
a blasphemous name
there's a connection of course between
the dragon and the beast the beast is an
extension of the dragon
you could see it as a manifestation of
the dragon's power on the earth
and when i say it like that i think it
should be easy to understand
so this power does not come from above
anymore
but rather comes from below from the
chaos of the sea
because the satan is a fallen
principality
a principality which opposes and
questions its connection
to what is above it and so it is related
to chaos so the beast comes out of the
sea
but is then a beast of the earth as it
affects
engages and actually dominates the world
of manifestation
becoming tyrannical
so it's also important to understand
the beast that's coming from below out
of the sea to rule
through a tyranny because this contrasts
with the later image
of proper order a proper order which
comes down from heaven to earth
in the form of the heavenly jerusalem
both the dragon and the beast have seven
heads and ten
horns the dragon has seven crowns on its
heads
but the beast has ten crowns and its
crowns
are on its horns so here once again it
is pointing
to how the beast and the dragon are
aspects of the same thing
the dragon is recognized it is crowned
it is rewarded on its heads or its
principles
because the head the rk the
chief the principle our biblical
concepts which all come together
you know in different places in
scripture these words are
interchangeable
and so its heads are not one but there
are many
we could say that they are the many
itself
so later in revelation those heads will
be more explicitly described
as principalities because they're said
to also
be seven mountains while at the same
time being seven
kings so these overlapping descriptions
are telling us that these heads are the
places where
authority and rule descend to lower
possibilities
unto a body in the case of a head a land
in the case of a mountain
and a people in case of a king
we can understand the seven heads as a
multitude of smaller rulers or
principalities
which should culminate into one under
god
but they do not in this way they are
multiplicity itself and we can
understand these heads
as akin to creation itself the seven
days of creation
though considered as separate in their
domain
and in their way separate from the
creator separate from the one
who unites creation together in himself
as the head of everything so if the
dragon is recognized for its heads the
other
the beast is recognized once again
crowned
rewarded on its horns it is the
extension of the dragon in the world and
not just the extension but
we could say something like a hardening
a condensation
and the way the dragon acts upon the
world
for the horn is a weapon and a tool of
domination
these extensions protrusions can be
understood in space
which a horn is already you know a
protruding into space
but later they will also be described as
an extension
in time an extension into the future as
kings
who have not yet received the kingdom
but will for one hour
share authority with the beast and here
the ten the ten horns
are like ten in most places in scripture
a symbol of a
of a completeness of totality so we can
understand this 10 in a way
which is very close to 666 that is an
as an expression of a totality of power
in the horns of the dragon and the beast
the idea of a totality of power is not
just there
in the horns you know but it's actually
borne out in the
rest of the description of that
surrounds the beast
the beast i saw resembled the leopard
but he had feet like those of a bear
and a mouth like that of a lion
this description refers to the prophecy
of daniel
where he saw four beasts a beast like a
lion
one like a bear another like a leopard
and a beast
with ten horns and iron teeth now this
prophecy is in the old testament so
before christ
and these beasts are almost always
understood
pretty much universally understood as
describing four kingdoms that succeed
each other over time
the babylonians the persians the
hellenistic empire of alexander
and finally the romans with their iron
teeth
it would be too much here to look at the
different animals and their
characteristics
but nonetheless we can easily see that
the beast
in revelation which comes out of the sea
because it is a combination of all the
former bees seen
in the prophecy of daniel is something
like earthly
power itself or the culmination of this
power into
an apex point which is why it is
described as
universal a world order having authority
over every tribe
every people and every nation one of the
heads of the beast seemed to have had a
fatal wound
but the fatal wound had been healed the
whole world was filled with wonder
and followed the beast
now many modern commentators have
mentioned that this passage
might refer to the early tradition
according to which nero
the degenerate emperor who first
persecuted christians
would after his death resurrect and
would return like a vengeful angel
and of course this was experience seen
as something
impending and immediate in the future of
the communities in the first century
but that tradition of the resurrection
of nero is
actually very interesting if we see it
rather
on the long term as a pattern which
could be something like
the possibility of an aspect of power
returning
of extremes of power a power which is
both
extremely tyrannical persecuting the
children of god the disciples of the
logos
while also being obsessed with pleasure
with orgiastic access and transgressive
sexuality
so you can understand this that's
containing the image i brought up
earlier
of this extreme vacillation between
chaos and tyranny
and of course this will make more sense
if we were to consider the
the pairing of the beast and the
prostitute which comes a bit later in
the text
maybe i'll do that in another video so
this question of nero of course warrants
my little
parentheses which is that many people
see these stories as discussing things
which happened long ago
describing ancient prophecies that have
already come to pass
some of which happened in the first
century itself
others see them only as predicting some
future event
so although those are in many ways
opposites to be honest
i have nothing to argue against either
of them i'd rather
prefer to understand reality as a
fractal pattern
and then the use of this highly
compressed and symbolic language
you know to speak about these things
also means that
these images are tapping into patterns
of being
so the descriptions obviously are not
arbitrary the fact that we're talking
about
beasts crowns water earth horns etc
all of these images are placed together
in a way which is coherent
and reveals to us how reality unfolds
they were just descriptions of things
that happened long ago or things that
will happen at some point in the future
then they would be almost useless to us
this or that beast refers only to
babylon or persia or rome
then why not just have said it at the
outset especially
now in the book of revelation babylon
was a long time before that
so no the highly codified language of
prophecy is important
because it is a language revealed and
refined
over centuries into becoming something
like a cosmic map
therefore if we see the description as a
cosmic pattern
which shows itself then understanding
the structure of these types of
descriptions can be
beneficial to us in every time period
even if we acknowledge that they also
refer to events that happened
and or will happen in the future
this goes also for the beast with seven
heads when mentioning that detail
i could already hear the objections of
people telling me that the seven heads
that the seven hills means that the text
is just referring to rome
and the answer to that is of course it
means rome to a certain extent
but it can't only be rome remember that
the seven heads are also seven
kings but the to the extent that rome
participates in this symbolism
one must ask ourselves what rome is
why rome is important what it means what
its pattern manifests can one think that
the fact that rome was seen as being on
seven hills is something completely
arbitrary
wouldn't it be more reasonable to posit
that the reason why rome was
importantly understood to be on seven
hills was because this was meaningful
to mention a meaning which reaches
beyond rome
and this meaning is possibly a part of
why
that this seven is emphasized in
revelation over
the multitude of other aspects about
rome which could have been mentioned
and it's probably this meaning which
also leads to the reason why
constantinople
the christian city was finally also
built
on seven hills just as rome was
in this vein beyond trying to identify
the wounded head of the beast
as this or that emperor as this or that
aspect of a historical kingdom
which in itself i you know i have
nothing against like i said
but we can also understand the fatal
wound of the beast and its healing
within the story itself
as a manifestation of the beast itself
arising as a totalizing power
so like i said the seven heads are akin
to the seven days of creation
the seven days of the week representing
a complete
cycle the sabbath or the day of rest
is the remaining day after the work of
god
and it's a day that's strangely
connected to a little death
in that sense so for example the mystery
of this sabbath
is revealed to us in the christian
tradition in which we say
that the sabbath was accomplished in the
day christ spent in the grave
after being crucified cinching the
connection
between this last day between rest
and death so one of the heads we could
say
the seventh head was deathly wounded it
was
incomplete and it manifested the
remainder
the mortality the imperfection the limit
of the beast
if one has read my brother's book the
language of creation
one might remember how he reveals
the seventh measure of the circle or the
cycle by its radius to be incomplete
and a remainder and one should not
underestimate the mystery metzier has
pierced in this insight about the circle
and the cycle
for it can also help us understand the
different ways
the heads of the beast are described
if one way of describing the heads of
the beast is that one is wounded in
another chapter
these same heads are described in time
as five past kings one present king
which is the sixth king
which we could call the measure or the
measurer of the cycle
as it is the present one and the seventh
who it is said will remain only a little
while
that is an incomplete measure
a remainder a coda etc
so the wound of the beast's head was
said to have been made by a sword
from a supposed enemy but because the
beast now is given dominion over all
people
there is no place from which to attack
the beast no possible enemy
the beast makes the wounded head
complete in its very
act of total dominion for there is
nothing left which can wound it
and this becomes a parody an imitation
of the resurrection
as well as the final pretension of
systems of power and control
to prevent death and chaos to prevent
death and disease
and by a universal claim to power also
eliminate
the possibility of an outside by
containing
the remainder and the exception and we
see this
in the next verse people worship the
dragon because he had given authority to
the beast
and they also worshipped the beast and
asked who is like the beast
who can wage war against it in this case
the question is obviously a bigger deal
than just a statement of strength for
who
in fact can wage war against the beast
if it totalizes
power over all people
another fascinating aspect of the
wounded head is that it says
the head appeared as wounded which
possibly not certainly but
possibly suggesting that the wounded
head might in fact be just
an appearance or a ploy a deliberate
explicit show
of illness which in its healing would
make the beast appear stronger
and more powerful than it actually is
this would be using the remainder the
deathly aspect of a system
as a trick to make the system even more
powerful
by showing how this imperfection can be
defeated
this is of course the whole aesthetic of
the false flag the
psyops the infiltrated demonstration
the tricky serpent here is doing in a
way the opposite of what it did in
heaven
but now for itself in heaven
it used its tail to question and oppose
the principalities
but hereby appearing to heal the wound
making the system complete
it is making its tyranny stronger the
beast was given a mouth
to utter proud words and blasphemies and
to exercise its authority for 42 months
it opened its mouth to blaspheme god and
to slander his name
and his dwelling place and those who
live in heaven
it was given power to wage war against
god's holy people and to conquer them
it was given authority over every tribe
people
language and nation
now all of these elements pride
blasphemy slander against that which is
in heaven
power over all people and power to wage
war against holy people
are of course all aspects of a central
pattern
in the totalizing system a system to
become independent from the transcendent
perfect and have authority on all people
first it must attack the supremacy
of that which is above it in this case
god or heaven secondly it cannot
stand those who preserve allegiance to
that transcendent
good for to do so undermines the
capacity
for the system to be total this might
seem to
seem a bit abstract but imagine when the
united states
declared its independence from its king
and not only had to go to war with the
king but it also had to eliminate
and chase away loyalists because
those loyalists undermined the integrity
and reality of the
self-declared independent united states
we the people though it purports to be
universal
secretly means we who are not loyal
to the king and although pretending
to be all the people this self-declared
we the people
this is a problem and loyalists
who used to manifest the reality of the
king's rule
now become bothersome become strangers
enemies
among us and must be purged one way or
the other
of course in the case of the united
states these loyalists could flee to
somewhere like canada
but in a system which purports to be
total
ruling over all people then there's
nowhere to go
legitimately they must hide let's say
in the wilderness and we see that in the
story of the woman and the child
which i won't go into now or else they
must be purged
this is important to understand because
it can help us to perceive
how secular humanism can never stop at
questioning
the existence of god or relativizing
religion
but it must in the end actively try to
eliminate
everything outside the secular and
ultimately attack those who still
believe
it also shows how tyranny is first and
foremost an
excess in the realm of meaning
for the beast is given a mouth to utter
proud words and blasphemies and to
exercise its authority
speaking of course is the first
expression of meaning
as we see in the creation narrative in
scripture where the world is created
by god speaking it into being but even
at a lower level
speaking unlike unlike just thinking is
directed towards the world
and engages the world by addressing it
and in doing so especially if
this speaking is from a place of
authority it orders reality by naming
by attributing categories but especially
by attributing
hierarchies of importance
but when authority is illegitimate two
things will happen in the realm of
meaning
the two things described here boasting
which we could call something like
self-naming
giving attributes to oneself in the view
of others
and we will also see waging war against
god's people
because he did not receive his crown his
name and identity from above
a self-declared king must boast
must slander and accuse the king or the
religious
authority from whom he should have
received his
authority and this is of course the
nature of blasphemies that were talked
about here
in the text the beast must attribute to
itself
the names of god the qualities of god
must
ultimately declare itself try to name
itself with the name
of god but you see every time we see our
own wills as supreme this is
something which we do ourselves it is
the taking of the fruit
of the tree a fruit that is supposed to
make us like god
but it's taking it for ourselves rather
than waiting until god gives it to us
from above
through his grace and so here this
process described
in revelation appears as the cosmic apex
of the fall
it is as if the fall of man and its
consequences
has borne its final fruits and has
filled the earth
it's as much the giving into the serpent
in the garden and it is
a cosmic finality of the tower of babel
and its pretention to both reach the
heavens
but also to rule over all people
all inhabitants of the earth will
worship the beast
all those whose names have not been
written in the lamb's book of life
the lamb who was slain from the creation
of the world
now this is the image of the solution
to the seven-headed beast so we're
presented with another beast
a lamb but this beast
does not boast does not have to impose
tyrannical order
but is sacrificed from the creation of
the world
it is given up and that is how it
receives
its authority and this
my friends this is the secret of reality
which is that reality is based
on sacrifice the highest aspect of
something
is not its rule over its parts
its capacity to hold its parts together
it's not its power not its boasting
but it's it's giving itself to that
which is above it
that from which it holds its authority
and identity
while also giving itself for what is
below it
so for example in a burnt offering there
is a part of the sacrifice
the spiritual part which is represented
by smoke
which goes up and is an act of worship
and submission to that which is above
you
and there is a part of the sacrifice
which comes down
the cooked meat and is eaten by those
for whom it is offered
we see we see this of course in christ
himself
who offered up his spirit to god on the
cross
while laying down his life for his flock
and giving them his body to eat
now once again it is worth looking at my
brother matsir's book
for more on this pattern as his
explanation
of the pattern of sacrifice is the most
pristine i have ever encountered
the way reality holds together is
ultimately not
through total systems of control but
through love
and here by the way people who only
accept the substitutionary virgin
of the cross and of sacrifice will also
have to deal
with this verse about the lamb because
it is said that the lamb is slain
from the creation of the world and one
of the important
aspects of the slam as it's described
earlier
in the text is that it has seven horns
and seven eyes and these horns are seen
as the seven spirits of god
and so it's very interesting here
compared to
the seven heads of the dragon the seven
heads of the beast here
the lamb has one head and it has seven
horns
it has seven extensions and these horns
are also
these seven horns that will be blown by
the angels and so it is this
extension of the will of god into the
world
rather than seeing these the seven
principalities or the seven heads
and so here it is the proper
relationship of multiplicity
to unity because as i said the lamb has
one head but then is able to
to see multiplicity and
is able to extend its unity into the
multiplicity
both in the image of the horns but also
like i said in the image of these
trumpets which are blown
out into the world that call and that
judge
that let's say declare
what's going to happen in reality there
would be much to say about that
but at least for now what suffices for
us is how the book of life
is related to the system of the beast
if the worshipers of the beast are his
through being branded by his external
mark
something we will explore in the next
video about the mark of the beast
the servants of the logos are also
accounted for
at a higher level in a higher identity
and story
by having their name contained within
the book of life
we see this could also have been
expressed in the same way that it was
for the beast in fact
there's another place in revelation
where we get this notion that
one receives the seal of god on one's
forehead
similarly as one receives the mark of
the beast there is a difference
but we won't go into that here we'll
talk about that in the next video
but these two ways of accounting for
identity are actually perfect
to get a full picture of how identity
and hierarchy work
one picture from above that is how our
names are contained in the book of life
which is held
by the logos we are held together in
that higher identity
but it can also be seen from below as
receiving
a name a seal which joins
us together and makes us share something
something in common amid all our
differences in particularities
so you can imagine receiving different
marks or seals from above
or reversely being contained into
different bodies or books
in this way when it's accepting
different levels of identity
to cover and contain you you could have
a mark at a political level
an identity is part of a family or a
group a parish
a football team for example i bear the
name of my ancestors
pajo while i'm also marked by being
quebecois by being canadian and at the
highest level
i am under the name of god by being in
his image and
participating in his body
these multiple levels of naming and
containing
containing names can normally coexist
since identities at different levels of
reality
fit into each other when the world is
laid out properly
so you won't be surprised that i'm going
to use the example of a chair as i often
do but
it works so the leg of a chair can be a
leg
while also participating receiving the
name of chair from above as it were
to the extent that it participates in
that higher identity
by being the leg of a chair and a part
of the body
of the chair and of course the leg
itself is also made of parts the parts
that have
names and reversely the chair can be
contained
in a higher identity like a dining set
for exam for example which
contains it from above in this normal
way different smaller identities
don't compete with higher identities
but because the system of the beast is
trying to be total it is
idolatrous in its structure
it must not only mark those who belong
to it give them its
name and better still its number
but also it has to attack those who are
marked
or contained at a higher level of life
and possibly at any other level
he must attack those who belong to god
once again and they must be eliminated
or
made to bow down and worship the beast
as the total system
totalitarian systems see themselves in
competition with all other
identities they are
similar to material reductionists who
see only one type
of identity and one type of causality
possible
in the world totalitarian systems
must break down families clubs
religious organizations and dare i say
they must reduce people
as much as possible to a number
in order to create fractured individuals
that they become pure quantity who only
have
this totalitarian system as their master
and identity
anna harond who wrote about totalitarian
systems famously said
terror can rule absolutely only over men
who are isolated
against each other
this of course it's a false
understanding of how reality works and
is inevitably vowed to destruction
then i saw a second beast coming out of
the earth it had two horns like a lamb
but it spoke like a dragon
it exercised all the authority of the
first beast
on its behalf and made the earth and its
inhabitants
worship the first beast whose fatal
wound had been healed
and it performed great signs even
causing fire to come down from heaven to
the earth
in full view of the people
all of this is why the second beast
makes an image of the first
and has the power to make it speak
of course this order of manifestation
could also be seen from the side of
light it's just
just an order of manifestation and there
are many examples
for example in the revelation on sinai
we see at first the invisible word of
god
which descends and then moves into the
law which is given
by god to moses and then
moses descending the mountain as the
prophet
who presents and gives the through his
authority the law that god has given him
and in the story of moses it's very
interesting because there's also the
making of an image
but this image that they make is a
reflection of the passions of the people
right and their will is portrayed as
being at the bottom of the mountain
rather
than being coming from above just like
the law was coming from above
and so the beast of course comes out of
the sea and
in this way this image of a beast of the
golden calf
is already an inkling of the image of
the beast in revelation
because of the signs it was given power
to perform on behalf of the first beast
it deceived the inhabitants of the earth
it ordered them to set up an image in
honor of the beast
the second beast was given power to give
breath to the image of the first beast
so that the image could speak and cause
all who refuse to worship the image
to be killed there are a lot of things
happening in this sentence of course
because the rule of the beast is a
totalizing system
because it wants to contain reality
within it
because it wants to take for itself the
qualities and names of
god then it must create
something akin to life
because it made war against the source
of heavenly
intelligences it must create
an artificial intelligence in order to
make people worship the beast and the
dragon
as they once worshipped the god against
whom the dragon made war
the god who created man by
putting his breath into him
of course this is a deception as
it is mentioned but it doesn't matter
of the things i've insisted on in
several of my recent videos is that it
doesn't matter
if general artificial intelligence is
possible or if it's actually realized
it only has to be believed in
you know to believe to be as such for
people to worship it
its intelligence its breath comes from
the beast
the puppeteer we could call it
and its representative the second beast
speaks like a dragon but presents the
horns of a lamb
and interestingly enough interestingly
enough
this might be the mystery of the
antichrist
though that's probably good to talk
about that at another time
the thing with revelation is that as
soon as you go into there are many
things that
that even now that i've skipped over
because
every sentence opens up into an infinite
not an infinite every sentence opens up
and every word
has to be kind of talked about and so
it's difficult to talk about everything
hopefully i've this been at least been a
good intro
to these descriptions of the different
beasts in revelation of course as you
can see i focused on
patterns of being rather than getting
excited about current events but
i do think that these stories are
nonetheless important
to understand current events and
we'll look at that a little more in my
next video in which
we'll be looking at the mark of the
beast itself